oh
i love when we're seeing another angle
of this god
here we go
here we go girl get away from that
seinfeld oh they're using the same
footage that's cool oh my god yeah
they're running
[Laughter]
up hawkeye clint barton with new protege
kate bishop but against whom
of the many shady characters on this
series is kate's mother eleanor bishop
secretly the one killing everyone we
don't trust that red gown no did she use
the battle of new york as a cover to
kill her husband what the hell what the
hawk what the hawk indeed this is inside
marvel our weekly after show for hawkeye
on disney plus from now through the end
of the year i'm eric voss and i'm here
with mtmt
hawkeye's here happy holidays he's here
hayley steinfeld is here with the bow
and arrow it's the most wonderful time
of the year i hear it is great for me
did you know it's christmas time in the
mcu because it's christmas time yes it
is um i'm getting that vibe a little bit
um a little lights here and there uh a
little christmas check we don't need any
turkey tomorrow it's christmas time
well a quick recap of episodes one and
two we get this crazy prologue showing
kate witnessing the battle of new york
from her own perspective
they love dipping back into that 2012
well you know that's how loki opened in
game love going back there we're just
gonna see like eight different layers
this is gonna be like order 66 of the
mcu i know
i mean it was a huge event it was like
basically the 911 of the mcu it's like
yeah things popped off but the mcu has
like had 10 911s at this point like yes
the snacks it was the original 911 of
the mca oog 911.
um so we find uh her parents eleanor and
derek arguing about money in a plush
midtown penthouse one percent of
problems apparently but a hawkeye arrow
saves kate from uh some chitari that are
coming to kill her but derek does not
survive hmm we don't know exactly what
happened with him but kate decides to
avenge her father's death by becoming an
archer a fencer a gymnast a martial
artist a trophy collector she does it
all folks she ends up getting uh
suspended or expelled from college for
collapsing a bell tower it looked like
it was from the family of obadiah stain
we find out that eleanor now runs bishop
security a private security firm
and kate attends a party where she
learns eleanor is engaged to jack decane
whose uncle armand does not approve of
this engagement but then kate snoops
down to a secret auction of collectibles
recovered from avengers compound
including clint's ronin gear and his
sword from avengers end game and but
then boom boom the tracksuit mafia bro
they sack this auction to steal some
mystery watch but in this chaos jack
grabs the sword and then kate fights the
track suits wearing clint's gear which
she was able to change into in record
time i got it hey man she just got the
skills like that it's wardrobe changes
like that you gotta have she has a
trophy for quick changes uh and the
action the stunts of this series are
awesome so
so good like i love the direction of the
show it honestly feels like the comic
come to life the matt fraction run so
right this all based on that fraction of
david aha comics it feels totally
exactly what it feels like to read those
comics so she saves a one-eyed dog lucky
the pizza dog from the comics though the
best character in this series i did so
far the best beat haley but it is the
dog
i know he has he has one eye taken out
but like that's vfx we've seen that dog
on set that's i think they just do a
little vfx on the dog's eye i i don't
know
how to do stuff because he's just always
winking at us he's got a secret it was
this dog all along
but no no i'm i'm fascinated to know
maybe that they might give this dog a
different name by the end of the show
like it was named lucky by clint later
on in the in the comics what if this
dog's name is like clint or something
like that by the way oh my god that
would be so
that would be kind of concerning because
that would be included with that
i know i know i know i don't want to go
there yet
who knows
[Music]
i don't know but uh big twist at the end
of this episode kate finds armand iii
[Music]
the little boy the little armada there
could only be
while all this is going on clint martin
takes his kids to see rogerson musical
on broadway i can do this all day
[Applause]
i loved it but clint hilariously just
lowers his hearing aids so i just have
to listen to it
i wish i had that option just like
i'm done
and this musical's taking liberties with
the events of the battle of new york
right like ant-man's there uh actually a
little tease for this week on new
rockstars we were able to get in touch
with nico de jesus who plays that guy
and he's gonna be on rogue theory this
friday
going into some series with us super
super cool dude please go see it amazing
yes uh so tune in to see more of that
but um
after this musical you know clint is
kind of triggered by watching these
events he's like why are they just
making light of it he has that moment
checking with the natasha dancer he
clearly is like my dead friend like
you don't blame him for wanting to tune
out of this but then uh
after they go back to the hotel room
after dinner uh he sees kate in his
ronin gear on tv and he's like uh oh
wait how am i on tv and standing here at
the same time
i don't understand telecommunications
but uh he goes out and finds her in the
street beats up all the tracksuit guys
and then unmasks her and she's like i'm
your biggest fan so that brings us in
episode two which things go by much
quicker here the tracksuits bomb kate's
flat with molotov cocktails she and
clint have to hide in her aunt's place
clint has to track down his ronin gear
uh one of the first responders is also a
larper named grylls
yes
grylls is also from the comics making us
nervous that this guy's name is grylls
right
[Music]
sorry this is really random but anybody
came up on the phone when when when
clinton found him
literally the hardest i've ever laughed
in mcu history like his video that he
put his tick-tock i've never looked like
that it's so funny so i loved it
um so i'm worried about this guy though
um but larping with all them does help
clint with his branding issues we had
that great moment in times square where
we see oh puny tourists and all the
other times square elmo's and all them
including katniss everdeen making hunger
games now mcu cannon i love it they're
just sucking in everything um but then
kate does not suspect jack one bit she
goats him into you know just a casual
dinnertime fencing match and she's able
to get out of him his secret badass
skills uh but then he offers kate a
butterscotch from armantom oh my god oh
my god oh my god and then she leaves
he's like it's just candy
a dead man's butter scotch how dare you
dead man
so clint allows himself to be taken by
the tracksuits as well as their
lieutenant cazzy the clown also from the
comics uh and uh he tries to get them to
stop hunting kate but they're like uh no
we hated that guy who did that he's like
but it was not her but it's not me but
it was him you know who had that history
with the track suits uh kate drops him
with no gun and we meet echo maya lopez
the gang's leader who's able to sense
the vibrations from the huge speakers as
she prepares most likely to pull their
teeth out but like she she's a deaf
superhero from the comics she's a badass
she's gonna get her own spin-off on
disney plus we actually talked about
echo in last week's episode of inside
marvel we're gonna go into her character
more as the series comes on but really
it's clear that eleanor bishop is hiding
something i think we should all agree so
what are her skeletons in the closet
does one of them have a shitty goatee
probably
but before we get to that our merch
partners at the epic hero shop are
having a huge black friday sale right
now with awesome discounts all over the
site huge announcement they're opening
up the vault of all previous latest
obsession shirts from loki the
mandalorian and more here is your chance
to get your hands on some of these
designs that were previously suspended
they're back alive and they're so rare
more ramp than the mcrib so get one
before they head back into the vault
find all of that at epicheroshop.com and
now that it's hawkeye season the newest
shirt in the latest obsession line is
awesome it is inspired by hawkeye and
when you get it you will get the added
option to write in a custom shout out
that will appear along the bottom of the
screen during these hot guy after shows
let's see what we have here oh lil
debbie asks could kate bishop's father
still be alive
that's an interesting thought i think
there was i think we're gonna revisit
the moment of his death or not death
just because we didn't see it and i
think we're gonna learn more about what
happened sassy cassie asks could lucky
the pizza dog actually be a flerkin
all
adorable pets in the mcu must be
flirting oh i mean hey yeah i don't
blame you for suspecting because you
know goose was kind of a surprise to a
lot of people but i think luck is a good
he's a he's a normal normal boy no more
winking boy uh and chester asks petition
for eric and mt to put bro at the end of
every question
i think bro i think you're right bro i
don't know if i can do that chester uh i
don't think that's in my system bruh
maybe i could do that bro you know
that's what i do bro all right empty
what's our big question coming out of
this episode well eric what the hawk is
eleanor bishop hiding because i do not
trust this chick at all eric yes me
neither empty let's recap so in the
prologue eleanor and derek bishop are
arguing about money something even
people in the midtown penthouses can't
help but talk about right it's the root
of all evil and everyone
uh is servant to the money overlords
well uh eleanor says that they need to
sell the penthouse derrick argues that
he'll be able to turn things around yeah
baby just give me another weekend baby i
got a big deal i'm gonna move some rugs
i got some rugs are gonna move it fell
off the end of a truck i'm gonna move
these things so fast maybe and it's like
what is this guy doing in this apartment
she's like a real housewife and he's
like i drive cars nobody's like yo
there's a hot game of dice outside i
feel i'm feeling lucky today baby i'll
be right back
he feels so uncomfortable at these fancy
parties like why can't i just get a beer
oh i don't know how to pronounce these
things on the menu can you just give me
some noodles with butter what's so hard
about that
the gravy just give me some he's like
like tony soprano's third tier down from
from the sanitation business 100 he's a
very he seems like but he also seems
like a very chill like dude like a more
relaxed person than eleanor is i mean
hey we're making fun of them but guys
like this totally exist in new york like
their wives are totally like spending
that cash and he's just like i make the
money
but anyway so during this fight uh
eleanor says that a solution won't just
fall from the sky but then one totally
does during the chaos of the battle in
new york the penthouse gets destroyed
derek is killed seemingly taking the
family's financial struggles with him to
the grave but did kate's dad really die
as a direct result of the battle in new
york or was something more sinister
going on in the bishop house that
morning well it's interesting to note
that in the comics it's kate's mother
that is out of the picture and her
father is a parental figure that she
butts heads with as a teen it's also
heavily implied that derek bishop was
responsible for eleanor's mysterious
disappearance and death so if mcu-kate
is being raised by her mother and not
her father could they also be flipping
the script on which bishop is a
power-hungry murderer let's investigate
because just before the battle began
derek told kate that he was heading
downstairs to his office and then
shortly after this eleanor told her
daughter the same thing that she'd be
downstairs but when eleanor came to
rescue kate after the explosion she was
alone and the viewers are both like left
to assume that derek died in the
wreckage but we never see a body no
corpse no death folks we want to see the
body drop and if we don't they're still
alive or they were murdered in some
other way
that is the rule for any piece of media
if you don't see the body it's a it's
suspect you don't know so we don't know
exactly what killed kate's dad if like
he was crushed by the building
collapsing why was eleanor able to
escape back up the stairs but derek
wasn't did the explosion somehow miss
her and only take out the husband i
guess it's possible but it's also
possible that eleanor sees the
opportunity to get rid of him once and
for all with a nice little shove like
she could have made the choice to leave
him behind a die or she could have
straight up murdered him when she
realized this battle would be a perfect
cover for his death like it just seems
like eleanor is gonna be a textbook
red-collared criminal aka a seemingly
normal person who turns violent to solve
their money struggles she wanted to move
out of the penthouse and poof the
penthouse was destroyed and she was
probably able to convince jake from
state farm to give her the insurance
payout
her husband was being irresponsible with
the finances well great he's not around
to do that anymore seems like the battle
of new york just solved all of eleanor's
problems hey man it's better than uh
marriage counseling you know yeah it's
murder
who no one has time for that no just you
know
just cut the wire as tony stark would
say uh but it's also worth questioning
whether eleanor took advantage of an
opportunity the chaos of the battle of
new york opened up to her or whether her
solution falling from the skyline might
have been a hint that she actually knew
what was coming and planned this ahead
of time premeditated it but in order for
that to be true what kind of character
could even possibly know that the
chitauri invasion was imminent that
caught the avengers off guard even in
that moment are we looking at a hydra
operative are we looking at a sorceress
or perhaps an extraterrestrial like a
skrull
oh my god if oh my what if oh my what if
oh my god what if oh my haley is oh my
god that would be nice that would be
absolutely nuts we got a theory train
leaving the station going off
no she has to be like pure human hailee
steiner failed secretivation was
announced empty we have to be looking
for scrolls under every rock this is
true one of those rocks
is part of the penthouse that just
collapsed it's also just worth pointing
out that eleanor bishop has something
weird going on with her body she is
surprisingly nimble
to impress kate she does this trick shot
catching the carrot in her mouth yeah or
if that was a carrot i don't know what
that was i didn't hear a crunch it was
something it was some kind of some type
of food object a food object there was
that photo of eleanor doing the
handstand on the cliff uh the opening
titles make it clear that eleanor
oversaw all of kate's training like she
doesn't freak out when kate and jack won
a fence in the foyer she can do more
than she lets on she's not that boozy
despite all the wine she's drinking she
can do a lot and then she also has got
shady friends that includes her fiance
jack duquesne who's of course based on
jacques duquesne the swordsman from the
marvel comics hawkeye's mentor he kind
of goes back and forth being a villain
but he's also kind of like an avenger
like he's a good guy and a lot of stuff
um but with his uncle armand the
duquesne family along with the bishops
seem to be a highly influential wealthy
family but clearly he has secrets and
kate suspects a liar right off the bat
from him she realized something was up
the moment she noticed her mom's
penthouse full of freaking swords
they've been doing some redecorating and
then eleanor and jack's engagement was
hidden from kate at first kate overhears
armand threatening eleanor saying don't
try that on me and reminding her that he
too has powerful friends so who could
these uh powerful friends be who are
both of them in league with working with
what elements of the criminal underworld
should we wonder about here and then
jack and armand attend this auction of
black market collectibles taken from
avengers compound now eleanor wasn't
there but she probably was aware it was
going on right she runs a private
security company like
i kind of have to wonder if jack could
have been her proxy during this auction
or just someone who was on the inside as
she knew what was gonna happen armand
suggested he's reached a breaking point
with eleanor there's some tension jack's
just like whatever old man i don't care
and during this debacle jack takes
hawkeye sword armand ends up murdered
via a sword
jack has a butterscotch from armada's
home we're clearly meant to suspect jack
but i think more is going on here so
empty i'm going to lay out my theory for
you i want to hear your thoughts all
right lay it on me bro okay i think
eleanor killed derek i think she has
blood on her hands from kate's father's
death and i think both of them the
reason they were so rich is that they
were both profiting from organized crime
in new york city but derek bishop was
just kind of the screw-up who maybe
inherited his position was not the true
brains of the operation i think eleanor
was the brains of that marriage she was
a fearsome fighter in her own right
maybe even madame mask in another life
uh and then after derek's death she
might have used her ducane connections
to forge her own ascendancy to the point
where she's now running bishop security
to give the elite criminals of the city
cover to engage in illegal activities
like black market weapons sales like we
saw in this episode episode one and i
think she knew about this auction she
sent the tracksuits though in to steal
that watch maybe a side deal that armand
didn't know about but jack totally did
and now they're trying to make us think
it was jack who killed armand maybe that
was the case i think it's also possible
that it was eleanor or whoever they
actually work for because i think
eleanor is in league with qazi and
league with echo and the track suits
they all report to her but it's also
possible that both echo and eleanor
report to someone above them like
kingpin and i think that watch
could have some sentimental value to
wilson fisk and that's why they were
sent to go retrieve it so that no one
else could bid on it what do you think
mt i i do like this a lot this makes a
lot of sense this makes a whole lot of
sense um and i do like the kingpin twist
because we i mean we do have a
inkling that daredevil's coming and you
know we couldn't yeah you know hopefully
i mean vincent d'onofrio back dinosaur
just tweeted last week saying he's
really excited it looks really fun like
i mean i don't know
i don't know empty
underworld of new york always has his
kingpin at the top of it exactly and
like it would be a huge sale for the
hawkeye series and all the disney plus
series in general to have you know that
daredevil netflix integration so i i
love it a lot though i do think in
regards to you know jack um himself i
think he's just an [ __ ] i think he's
just a jerk who just really likes swords
and he's you know he's rich and eleanor
is taking advantage of this i think that
eleanor
is kind of a uh you know a gold digger
type person who's just that much player
yeah she's like i'm gonna leach off of
derek and then i'm gonna kill derek and
then i'm gonna leech off of jack i'm
gonna you know when i'm done with jack
i'm gonna you know move our way to the
top and it feels very
hydra like to me because that's what
hydra does throughout history they latch
themselves because hydra themselves are
not nazis they worked with the nazis
which is kind of they were worse than
that
which is literally where's the biggest
thing
and then like when the nazis were done
they latched on to the other
organization this is what they do and so
i think that eleanor could potentially
be a human personification of that um
and we could be because like like you
said
it's weird that she knew that the so it
sort of feels like she knew that the
battle was coming which she said like oh
you know a solution can't just fall from
the sky wink but shield knew that loki
was on his way to new york and that new
york was going to be a
a point of where what's going to happen
so since shield was compromised she
could have known ahead of time so just
so you're saying she might be madame
hydra
i don't know madame hydra but it feels
very hydra-like i mean it would be cool
if it was mito hydra but like i don't
know it just it just feels like
what whatever is going on it just feels
very hydra like to me and i feel like at
least maybe she has hydra connections
who knows i think we need to pull our
audience like what are um eleanor
bishop's secret loyalties is it with uh
hydra is it with the skrull empire uh is
it with uh some kind of sorceress uh
connection i think that'd be kind of
crazy we haven't seen much evidence of
that uh is it with kingpin uh or is she
just on her own plan like is she her own
woman she seems to be fully uh capable
of running her own criminal empire just
on her own merits strong independent
woman yes she is but i want to talk more
about this watch uh in a second we have
more questions about this watch uh but
first we want to thank butcherbox for
sponsoring this episode quality really
matters when it comes to the meat that
will be the centerpiece of your holiday
meals and when you invest in high
quality meat from butcher box the
benefits go way beyond a great tasting
meal we are big fans of the beef in pork
options from butcher box off-screen
producer zach made some of their pork
ribs recently they were a big hit every
month butcher box ships a curated
selection of high quality meat right to
your home each box contains between 8 to
14 pounds of meat depending on the box
you choose that's enough for 24
individual meals they're packed fresh
and shipped frozen for convenience so
you can save time on your next grocery
store trip customize your own box or go
with one of theirs either way you'll get
exactly what you want this holiday
butcher box is proud to give new members
free new york strip steaks for a year
this deal has been offered before and it
won't last forever get two delicious 100
grass-fed new york strip steaks for free
in every box for a year this offer is
only available until november 30th 2021
so get it before it is gone just go to
butcherbox.com
marvel to sign up that's butcherbox.com
marvel to receive this limited time
offer of free new york strip steaks for
a year also thanks to coinbase for
sponsoring us if you've been following
the cryptocurrency craze now is the time
to start getting involved coinbase makes
it quick and easy to start your own
portfolio and learn to trade like a pro
coinbase offers a trusted and easy to
use platform to buy sell and spam
cryptocurrency they support the most
popular digital currencies on the market
and make them accessible to everyone
they offer portfolio management
protection learning resources and a
mobile app so you can trade securely and
monitor your crypto all in one place
millions of people in over 100 countries
trust coinbase with their digital assets
whether you're looking to diversify just
getting started or searching for a
better way to access crypto markets
start today with coinbase and for a
limited time new users can get 10
in free bitcoin when you sign up today
at coinbase.com marvel sign up at
coinbase.com marvel for ten dollars in
free bitcoin this offers for a limited
time only so be sure to sign up today
that's coinbase.com marvel also getting
underwear or socks for christmas used to
be a joke those were the bummer presents
you hated to get but stance has changed
all that with their comfy colorful gear
these are the kinds of stockings you
will be thrilled to have stuffed in your
stocking stance's premium line of socks
apparel and more always comes correct
with colorful designs innovative
materials and choice fits that are built
to last their all-star collaborator
lineup also sets the brand apart they
have really cool current collaborations
with brands that new rockstars fans will
enjoy like marvel star wars batman and
pixar there's also some really cool
holiday themed socks with clark griswold
the grinch and buddy the elf on them so
check out stance.com for all the latest
including several different subscription
options that are sure to keep your
friends and family feeling great all
year round stance has a perfect gift for
every punk and poet on your list go see
for yourself it's easy just head on over
to stance.com and pick out some styles
you think they might like enjoy the
color and comfort of a life less
ordinary with stance autumn is in the
air the pumpkins are in the patch and
our friends at manscaped are here to
make sure you don't carve your pants
pumpkins when you're grooming
make sure you're keeping things fresh
this fall with the leaders of male
grooming and their brand new fourth
generation performance package join the
two million men worldwide using manscape
by going to manscape.com marvel for 20
off plus free shipping look i'm not
afraid to admit uh there have been times
i've been grooming downstairs and i
ended up on my own naughty list but
manscaped has helped my confidence now
because the manscape performance package
4.0 includes the lawnmower 4.0 trimmer
as well as the weed whacker ear and nose
hair trimmer croppers over ball
deodorant crop reviver toner performance
boxer briefs and travel bag to hold all
these goodies and uh this 4.0 trimmer
i'm telling you i can i can just trim
with confidence
i'll be on my own nice list from now on
this fourth generation trimmer
features a cutting-edge ceramic blade to
reduce grooming accidents thanks to the
advanced skin safe technology it also
gives you the ability to turn the 4000k
led spotlight on and off when needed for
a more precise shave plus the whole
thing's waterproof so get 20 off and
free shipping by going to manscape.com
marvel that's 20 off and free shipping
by going to manscape.com marvel make
your balls a priority this fall choose
manscaped your balls will thank you all
right mt
what the hawk was the watch that was
taken from avengers compound i i threw
out a theory that maybe this could be
tied to kingpin this is something from
wilson this collection that was
confiscated he was happy to get it back
mt what do you think this watch was yeah
so i have two kind of weird theories
here um it very well i think you know
one you know the more
obvious one is you know it could be a
piece of stark tech because avengers
avengers compound is very stark heavy
and you know everyone wants that stark
technology um so it could just be a
piece of star tech connected to you know
quantum realm because i really do think
that quantum mania the term quantum
medium is in reference to the quantum
energy um race that um sunny birch
alluded to in ant-man 2. oh um like
maybe they're really close to building
like a quantum gate and they just need
something in that watch as a final like
clue or the final thing to get them to
finally um master that however another
theory that i have is you know
with i think this this could also be
stark tech related but in another way
because we know that eleanor is a
security lady she runs a security thing
what if she is doing security for the
new stark facility and like she needs
and she wants to break into it and open
up a safe but she doesn't have the last
piece and like the watch is like that
piece of stark technology so i'm just
trying to think of what security she's
running that is evil for evil purposes
and like it's yeah who knows i would
love to see if
x-con shows up here as a uh
that'd be amazing i would love that so
much it's just interesting it seems like
a lot of things are pointing toward
armor wars right like from
the winter soldier uh you had sharon
carter as a power broker uh she had
other buyers on the phone and then as
you mentioned sunny birch from ant-man
the wasps he was working for a buyer as
well some mystery buyer uh and then we
saw in the spider-man no way home
trailer it seems like stark tech is
getting into the wrong hands a doc ock
has uh the nano bots from the iron
spider armor now on his arms uh also
uh i'm pretty sure there is a stark arc
reactor chest reactor in that final
battle on uh on electro's chest like
that's another kind of football that is
in play in the mcu now so yeah i think a
lot of people are trying to get their
hands on stark tech i'm wondering if
this watch could be part of the mark 46
armor from civil war remember that he
had
the watch that he pulled over his hand
and he was able to use that to block
bucky's gunshot remember when bucky
tried to shoot iron man in the face
yikes
iron man remembers and he's dead but um
yeah so i wondered if this this could be
one of tony stark's watches that was
connected to that uh i'm just i love
that all these toys are still in the toy
box right and like i wonder if we're
gonna see damage control in this season
because you know damage control was a
really big part of um homecoming and
like you know they were the part of
vultures whole crew getting all their
stuff and so with this huge spaceship
and the huge wreckage of end game
happening
all sorts of goodies uh to pour over and
like that is not going to stay contained
into the you know the proper places it's
going to spread all over the world
that's what happens when aliens show up
that's what happens but mt i want to ask
you what the hawk really happened to
derek bishop could he still be alive to
answer little little debbie's question i
think that derek is dead
uh i think derek's gone
um but i definitely think that he was
murdered by eleanor there is no way that
he was killed by chatari that quickly
like literally like it's like oh let's
get out of here it's like where's dad
dad was literally downstairs with you
like you said it's like he was
downstairs with you it's too sketchy
like she was murdered by eleanor eleanor
as a cold and like you can tell by the
way that eleanor interacts with kate
that she's sort of really just
cold and manipulative in a weird way
it's a very weird like manipulative of a
relationship and like yeah yeah it's
it's it's it's very
you got just watch it again if you
haven't seen it but it's very it seems
very subtly obvious if you're aware of
it yeah i don't think it's subtle at all
empty i i think like it's clear that um
eleanor is grooming kate to take over
for whatever crazy super abilities uh
eleanor secretly has uh she's grooming
kate to like follow in her footsteps to
take over the security company and be
just as evil as she is so i think you're
right i think you're onto something
there uh and uh i don't think derek
bishop is still secretly alive because
that would just mean that eleanor bishop
is less evil and i think she's evil yeah
like and what what's the reason to keep
him alive for like do you have like
blood
like kill me
oh you're just trying to die no you
still have a piece of a liver left in
there
for the next auction it's like we're
saving you for a vision and uh and a
zombie wanda
your body parts slowly being here
so eric next question what the hawk was
going on the day of the battle of new
york in the city yes i think this
argument over money suggests that there
was something going on some kind of
dealing and i find this fascinating that
they're revisiting this one day in the
city because like you know there are all
these stories about the day of 9 11 in
new york city there's about to be a big
drug bust there's gonna be a big raid
like against like criminal elements and
this is real life this isn't me making
this [ __ ] up in 9 11 in new york in 2001
nypd there was there was going to be
this big drug bust that happened but
then obviously way bigger story
happening that day so i love that like
in the mcu they may imply there was a
lot of things going on that day and then
chattari invasion everyone's focus
shifted and i'm wondering if we might
find out that between the bishop family
the duquesne family potentially the fisk
operation uh there might have been all
this other stuff going on and they all
were able to exploit those events in
different ways and then kind of reforge
their own destinies and you know the
whole balance of power shifted that day
and because everyone's eyes were focused
up at the sky
people uh had blinders on for what was
going on in their own pockets and yeah i
think this is a ripe opportunity to
bring in wilson fisk as someone who is
able to to manipulate dodc and these
other organizations we already know that
was happening with the adrian tombs
operation right so who is in league with
adrian tombs and scavenging all this
tech who who really profited from the
battle of new york i think it's there's
a reason why we're visiting that day and
it's not just to show us kate
bishop's origin story i think it's to
suggest that a lot of people were
affected by those events in various ways
oh yeah and like you know in in the
original daredevil series on netflix the
battle of new york was like the main
focus of a lot of people's past it was
constantly referenced as like the event
or you know and and all that stuff so i
feel like maybe potentially in like
because we you know we do have rumors of
kingpin and daredevil we could see the
the origins of daredevil in another 2012
flashback
that'd be dope it would be so crazy like
because that
why a truck could just crash and fall on
a small child to make him blind um
nothing's going to fall on this child
like the chemicals follow the child this
truck fell the child the child would be
a swoosh child um but yeah no i think
that this would be a great way to do
like all right this is young matt
murdock chitari made him blind i mean my
hope is that like it still is just
charlie cox and they find a way to
suggest that like matt murdock from the
from the netflix series can just be in
the mcu you know like like he would be
that age i don't i don't think we need
to see that the truck accident again or
maybe like we revisited the one that we
saw i i just think charlie cox is so
great in this role if we can find some
kind of like multiversal explanation to
how he can just be in the mcu he'd be
perfect you know i think that you know i
think you can do both i think that you
can have like the same events
of like the story of like his origin
happen but like
sort of twist his uh origin story a
little bit but like since there
technically could be variants i don't
really know how the contract is with
netflix and like whether what elements
of the show they can use
um like do they just fully own
everything no no i don't think disney
owns the netflix series netflix owns
those but yeah i'm thinking but
netflix's contract with charlie cox is
up and uh i i don't think they can make
new ones the rights reverted to marvel
and i just don't know how much they can
reference from the original netflix
series is what i'm saying yeah i don't i
don't know i think they can bring in the
actors but i don't think they can like
show footage and say that was yeah you
cannon you know so i think that'll do a
lot of implications like all right this
is matt murdock and like the events of
daredevil that you know happened we're
not gonna say it happen but like here's
our origin and like here's a variant of
matt murdock and we're just going to
continue because
this is because the same thing happened
to him here too so whatever right i
think that's probably the cleanest way
to do it to suggest everything that
happened the netflix shows was like an
alternate side universe but like in this
universe matt murdock still looks like
charlie cox yeah he's just also
daredevil in this universe i don't think
too many fans would question it if
that's the narrative that was presented
because they could easily just do it
just incorporate it without saying
anything just subtly yeah just do it
just do it charlie cox i guarantee you
charlotte cox vincent d'onofrio
uh they're all they're all down for it
they're all they all wanted 100 everyone
wants that marvel money i wanted to ask
umt why do you think armand like i get
why jack duquesne wanted the sword
because he's a swordsman he wants it why
do you think armand wanted that sword in
particular just like a collector's fancy
or was it something else
it could have just been a collector's
fancy because like i don't think that
armand was a bad dude i think that you
know he was trying to warn kate about
her mom he's like your mom
kind of a kind of a bad person
that's a really weird thing to say to
somebody's daughter but he was just
straight up it's like yeah i don't
really like your mom but you know
whatever um
and you know i just think that he was
just like i just want this sword because
he was probably into swords too like his
son i think he his son got his love of
swords from his father and like it's
just something that the the armond
family do and so they were just bidding
on the sword because they both like
swords i think that's just what it is um
well jack was doing it because like he
was just being a jerk um but like you
know i think that he knows that his dad
will do it because he knows that his dad
loves swords i mean maybe it's just the
recency bias but i do think it's
interesting that this series drops just
a few weeks after eternals and eternals
kind of has this sub fascination with
swords with blades in the mcu i mean
literally blade in the mcu but we have
the ebony blade and they mentioned
excalibur both kind of having this
interesting history and then yeah when
he opens up the box it's the ebony blade
inside it's clearly cursed it's
whispering to him like
i i think that there might be just these
old families having these fascinations
with these swords obviously hawkeye
sword is a new thing that he built you
know during the blip but yeah i'm
wondering if there just could there's
we're going to learn more about the
history of all these old families uh in
the mcu uh with you know duquesne like
is there some kind of duquesne lineage
the fact that there are so many armands
we're gonna learn about these old
generations of these families uh that
are all have these obsession these
fascinations with these swords you know
uh and that armada wants to collect it
so that someone else can't right yeah
and like now that i'm thinking about it
i'm i'm thinking that maybe armand and
the armond family have some type of
connection to batroc and his people from
falcon and winter soldier because we
know nothing about you know his little
mercenary gang and like we know in the
comics that you know batroc and
swordsman were in a group together i
forget the name of the group right now
uh briefly and we remember from the the
credits of falcon winner soldier we see
like a sword logo kind of like a purple
sword logo um sort of like implied i
believe to be connected to backtrack and
his people um so i'm thinking that
there's some type of bad truck
connection there and since you know 2012
is this you know time rate maybe we'll
see bad track again maybe like we'll see
backtrack on a flashback um between we
would need to because that guy's dead
mega dead he got they they killed him
well i want to end empty with talking
about echo maya lopez a new member of
the mcu gonna get her own show i just
love this moment this introduction of
her just like her hand on the speaker
she does that to the tracksuit guy uh he
seems to have like a genuine respect and
fear of her he doesn't do any kind of
eye roll or anything like that
like he's clearly afraid of her i want
to know how she rose to such a level of
respect among the track because these
guys seem pretty like they have no
respect for kate bishop for anybody else
but echo they they fear her so i want to
know what what's her backstory like what
do you think i have this weird feeling
that you know just because of how she
was introduced we she's introduced in
this red lit room and i'm just like hmm
what if echo is from the red room what
if like they're making it oh literal red
room yes oh cool that's why they they
tinted it red and then she's just like
a red room um survivor and she's and she
can copy people's powers like taskmaster
so i'm sure semester was not the only
person that they you know did stuff do
in that manner so taskmaster successor
of the
oh man we got to go look through the the
uh black widow flickering screens to see
if we see maya lopez's or aloha cox's
face in there somewhere because there's
all those young girls all over the world
could she have been another black widow
initially empty golden rogi for you i
have these i know it's not rogue theory
but that man what a cool theory i'd even
think about that um but the fact that
her powers are so similar to taskmaster
she would be a perfect taskmaster 2.0 uh
for the mcu like
obviously echo is a completely different
character in marvel comics i totally
understand that but like the way they
did taskmaster in the black widow movie
i wasn't crazy about uh but like echo
could just be like a better version of
that yeah because like you know you got
to remember to well what melina was
talking about during that dinner scene
like they there was this huge research
going on into trying to hack the human
mind and trying to you know break
people's free will so taskmaster is not
the only person and like obviously
although all the widows were not the
only like experiments that they were
doing um and so yeah there's going to be
other people that can
copy people's powers and whatnot in the
end i mean we know there was like lots
of uh widows who ended up in all other
kinds of work elena bulova obviously
button
we saw one in the macau uh fighting club
that's part of like the criminal
underworld like where are they where are
the other widows could this yeah we
might see another widow in ant-man the
wasp quantomania with the introduction
of potentially nadia van dyne who is
another ant-man hero ant-man themed hero
who you know is the wasp she's the next
wasp after um the wasp
the second loss i guess
the third wasp and she comes from the
red room so i think that this is you
know marvel's trying to set up
you know these heroes coming out of the
red room because like there's a lot of
badass girls coming out of there and who
needs uh we need places in the mcu so
i'm all about it empty can i just
compliment you on the on your regional
dialect and the way you say rum
you say red ro you say red room which i
know you're from the boston area and
that's how a lot of people just say
different things
but it's like so charming because i'm
i'm just thinking danny from the shiny
like red rab red rub chase
rap
i i barely have a boston accent but
there's some little words like that like
i'll say wicked all the time people like
what do you say uh how do you say
luigi's brother mario okay you say it
right yeah
i know some friends from the new york
area they go they go mario mary nothing
wrong with that
yo so many of my teachers growing up are
you playing
or he's playing mario under there that's
it
yeah it is separate
man and mario
the teachers couldn't get it uh well
that is it for this episode of inside
marvel we're gonna be back next week
with our reaction to episode three but
don't forget to check out our many great
merch options at newrocksourcemerch.com
you can follow me at ea boss follow mt
at mastertainment follow new rockstars
subscribe to inside marvel wherever you
get your podcasts thank you for watching
we're gonna close with our favorite
moment from these first two episodes
[Music]
is
you